are you ready for spring cleaning
projects and renovations
well the clark county credit union has a
special loan that can help you next
season take a look
how do we keep our finances in shape you
know as we're trying all these new home
improvement projects and cleaning up
the place so one really good option
is a home equity line of credit which
you can
borrow against the equity in your home
to finance your home projects your home
improvements
extensions on the house front yards
backyards swimming pools
are really popular right now because
once the construction
is done with the pool summer's here and
we can enjoy it
exactly so you've mentioned that home
equity line of credit right how does
that work
so what we do is you can borrow against
the equity in
your home and to finance your home
projects
whatever really the sky's the limit it
doesn't matter what you need the money
for but it's a really good way to
finance home projects
because we're using your home as
collateral we're able to charge a lot
lower interest rate than say
you know a home depot credit card using
your home as collateral allows us
to offer a much lower rate
the term is 15 years so that makes the
payment very manageable
can any homeowner use that as long as
you have enough equity
in your home to borrow clark county
credit union will allow up to
an 85 loan to value home equity line of
credit which is a pretty high loan to
value
i know uh most lenders are not even
doing
home equity loans right now because of
you know the state of
the world so but we are and we're one of
the only local lenders doing them
and i know that our rates are very
competitive
what are some of the more common um home
improvement projects you've seen
that people use the the heloc for
a lot of swimming pools this time of
year i've seen a lot of
home approval loans for swimming pools
i'm doing a loan right now
for a homeowner who's building a casita
on the side of his house for his father
i'm
seeing front yards i'm seeing backyards
um
fixing all of the bathrooms um and it's
good to get the line of credit because
you can take what you need as you need
it and make payments only on what you've
used
so lots of times when you start breaking
down walls
issues can come up and that's why it's
so important to have a credit union that
you can trust
right absolutely so bottom line is call
me
call us i will let you know how much
your house is worth how much equity
you have to borrow we will make it work
definitely okay here's my next question
so
why would someone use the heloc over a
home equity loan what's the difference
between the two
so the differences are a home equity
loan is an installment loan
so you get all of the money up front
when the loan funds
so you're paying interest in making
payments on that entire amount of money
whether or not
you've spent it with the home equity
line of credit
it's a line of credit for the first five
years of the 15-year term
so you can take money as you need it and
your payments are based only on your
balance not your limit
so as you draw more money off the line
your balance
adjusts accordingly
start planning with the clark county
credit union call
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org they're offering heloc rates
as low
as 4 percent right now